[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
apparently there was a bomb threat
has anyone seen the petty Yeti lately
where is she
[Music]
someone get the location on Marjorie
Taylor green
and of course there's a bomb threat they
they told you this at CPAC in Texas uh a
while back that they are all domestic
terrorists of course they are the tens
of people have showed up to
support their orange deity this morning
some of them holding uh pig heads on a
stake
uh vivec Vivek the other the other
unknown running for president United
States is simping for Donald Trump
demanding demanding that all
of the other candidates pledged that
they will pardon Donald Trump
you know to receive a pardon novivec you
have to admit that you're guilty that's
part of the pardoning process I don't
know if you know that uh apparently
Donald Trump can't find an attorney
still this morning
can you imagine being so toxic that all
the ambulance Chasers are like no thanks
no thanks
I mean you're just you're just no toxic
pile of sludge when even the scumbags of
the scumbags of the scumbags
won't even [__] represent it's Miami
folks
do you have any idea how corrupt Miami
is and you can't find one [__]
attorney
this is where Scarface was set for a
reason
and you can't find an attorney to
represent you in Miami do you know how
pathetic that is I mean he is truly
[__] pathetic
apparently we're not gonna get a mug
shot they are gonna fingerprint him on
the electronic hand scanner
so there's gonna be official uh
Fingerprints of a former president
inside a federal case we won't see them
like even if they were gonna mug shot
him we wouldn't see his mug shot and
this this is quite different than the
New York case and that this is a federal
case this morning it is a different
judge than Canon as we know and going to
arraign him that that judge last night
said that they're he's not going to
allow any kind of electronic devices or
cameras in the courtroom as the Press uh
requested I told you that they they
wouldn't they don't normally what
cameras inside of a federal courtroom we
will have her probably get some sort of
sketch I'm sure there's going to be a
sketch artist to document
the interior of the courtroom as Donald
Trump is being arraigned if he is a rain
today that's really the question is is
it going to be arraigned he has to find
an attorney to represent him I don't
think that this judge is going to let
Trump represent himself I I wish that he
would
how [__] awesome would that be to let
this guy stand out in court and say all
kinds of crazy lunacy
in front of a federal judge when he's
facing 37 felony counts some of them
holding 20 years I think the total is
over 300 years worth of prison time that
this holds maximum now they don't really
do that in federal court
they don't they don't pile each charge
on top for sentencing you know if the
max max is 20 they'll give you 20. a
good examples like Stuart Rhodes
that recent history when you're talking
about treasonous pieces of [__] who love
Trump
that's how you want to see it
oh man
it is it is going to be something else
though because apparently it seems like
to me that they chose the Miami
Courthouse to do the arraignment uh for
the purpose of security and the reason
why is because apparently there's an
underground underground parking garage
where they can pull in and he can enter
the courthouse without even being seen
and he can exit the courthouse without
being seen now if you're wondering if
you're standing around wondering what a
two-tier justice system looks like it's
the fact that this guy has been afforded
all the leniency
at the Department of Justice the FBI and
Nara this entire time
um he's being provided special treatment
being being escorted to the courthouse
where no one can see him no one can take
pictures of him
he's being afforded the privilege of not
having to take a mug shot
okay these are all privileges this is
all part of the second tier
um most people who are tried under the
Espionage Act don't walk out of a
[__] Courthouse I don't know someone
someone call reality winner and ask her
uh when she went free someone someone
give her a call yeah they don't you
don't normally just when you commit
Espionage and you're charged with it
you don't just walk out of the
courthouse it's not how it normally
happens so yeah Micah there is a
two-tier justice system here you're just
really [__] pissed off that there's a
cheek in the armor that the second tier
isn't going to fully protect Donald
Trump anymore
that's what they're mad about
and all the while did you notice last
night they're like um
our orange deity's gonna be indicted on
37 failings but but there's there's um
someone said now um read Giuliani told
somebody who told someone else that told
the FBI that there's um there's
recordings of um Hunter and uh possibly
the big guy and I don't they're really
not recordings I mean we just think they
were someone's saying there's recordings
and there's a whistleblower who probably
isn't really a wristbot he's probably
paid by cash Patel and Trump to say that
he's whistleblower and that there's
recordings and and they're saying that
there's recordings of of a payment and
it is not really a payment not really
recordings get the [__] out of here with
this nonsense
it you know they always do this [__] let
me tell you something they always give
away their [__] stupid game always
it's all projection it's all a [__]
confession they're telling you you're
get their game plan before they even do
it
and here's why they were on Fox News I
showed you Clips the other day of these
[__] Republican sludge going on
traitor TV news networks and saying
isn't it convenient that the day we find
out that Joe Biden paid five million
dollars that we have no evidence of a
payment and blah blah blah Isn't it
convenient that that's the date Donald
Trump is getting indicted isn't it
convenient that you [__] idiots yell
and scream about 17 tapes and recordings
that don't exist
because you can't release them you can't
find them you can't even find them in
Jim Comer's ass
that use that you talk about that the
night before Donald Trump gets arraigned
come on man
you're giving away the game and then and
then last week when we when we saw the
indictment right and there's a
transcript of a recording of trump
saying yeah I I can't declassify these
documents I'm no longer the president
and I really can't even show you these
because they're classified and I didn't
declassify them the exact opposite of
what he was saying they were like oh
that's all AI That's not real and they
haven't even heard the [__] thing yet
they haven't even heard the tape
they haven't even heard the Trump tape
yet that is transcribed in the [__]
Federal indictment and they're like yeah
it's AI
so my guess is my guess is when when
audio does emerge of Joe Biden
committing crime it sounds eerily
similar to AI
how how are they how are we losing to
such amateurs
they're terrible at this they're
horrible at this
how are we losing to them we're not
losing to them that's the key
that's the lie that's the really big
[__] lie not that he not that he won
in 2020 that's not the big lie it's not
the big lie we all know he didn't
[__] win
there's no evidence at all
that there was any kind of discrepancies
that would swing an election anywhere in
this country not one state not one
County not one polling place
not one shred of evidence I mean other
than the villages
in Florida where they were voting four
and five times for Trump I mean other
than that place
but that doesn't necessarily make Biden
the president doesn't it Jesus Christ
but there's plenty of evidence
plenty of evidence in this indictment
material evidence this indictment and
that's what they're terrified of
that's what Trump's terrified of this
morning that's why there's bomb threats
that's why there's going to be more
threats that's why the [__] circus is
down
at the Miami Courthouse
because that's the only thing they have
is the circus
but they're so bad at this and half the
country doesn't support Trump again
that's the big lie that half the country
supports him it's [__] nonsense
I would imagine I would imagine that
there's going to be plenty of people who
are going to sit this one out because of
him and they're not going to be
Democrats they're not going to be
moderates and independents
they're going to be Republicans who are
going to sit this out
and if we don't take advantage of that
if we as a pro-democracy coalition don't
politicize the ever-loving [__] out of
that
and draw wedges in between them
where's Ron DeSantis where is he where
where is Ron DeSantis this morning
is he running a [__] campaign is he
because he acts like he doesn't have an
opponent this morning is there a
statement is there a video
is he sweating his balls off with
pudding on his fingers where's the video
Ron where's the statement Ron
why aren't you competing Chris Christie
tried to land a punch and still can't
land punches on Trump
which is very surprising by the way
very surprising
that Chris Christie can't even land a
punch
is it though is it surprising folks this
is a cult
he is their cult leader
they have made this bed they're gonna
[__] sleep of it even Paul Ryan this
morning doesn't get it he gets it right
up to the point where he doesn't get it
I'm gonna show you a clip Paul Ryan
this guy was the speaker of the house he
was forced to be the speaker of the
house by the way he was railroaded into
it because there was no one else that
would take the job
and this [__] doesn't even
understand what's going on
hell half the punditry doesn't the media
doesn't even understand I'm listening to
the media this morning they're so
[__] full of [__]
I've been telling you for months folks
months that he's gonna be the nominee
I've been telling you for months that
he's not going to see a trial until
after the election he won't see a trial
until after the election
on pod Saves America oh god well let's
just default to them pod Saves America
you talk about some [__] ass [__]
content tis James if you really want to
go on liberal media real liberal media
come on here don't keep going to pod
Saves America okay
with this Democrat political operatives
that don't know [__] about [__] they
don't know [__] about Americans they
don't that's that's why Democrats
continue to [__] lose in some of
these pockets of the country because
they don't know [__] these Elites don't
know [__] about you
pod Saves America get the [__] out of
here but Tish James on pod says America
gives away the hint that I've been
telling you for [__] months months
and months and months and months I've
been telling you
that this [__] is not going to
see a trial
until after the election he's gonna be
the nominee folks
get with the [__] facts get with the
reality that we're living with this is
where we're at this is the battle that
we have to fight in this next election
because there isn't going to be a jury
until after the election so we are the
jury it's us
we are the [__] jury
and we have to convince all the other
jurors
to convict
do you have do you follow me
we can start right now right now today
and some of the best ways to do it is to
mock them
some of the another good way to do it is
to talk the truth but talk it in a way
that the American people want
they don't want to be talked to our Act
they want to have a [__] conversation
a real [__] conversation without your
stupid [__] data and your stupid
[__] polls That No One Believes is
real
that's what they want
they don't want you to treat them like
they're not as smart as you
leftist that's right I'm talking to you
now leftist
we're gonna we're gonna have to have
some come to Jesus moments if you want
to call it that
in the pro-democracy coalition
uh last night Gavin Newsom here's
another good example Gavin Newsom goes
on Sean Hannity last night absolutely
[__] destroys d santis
and destroys Sean Hannity in real time
now
everyone wants to say oh Gavin should be
the candidate Gavin Newsom was on there
Pimpin Joe Biden dummies
Gavin Newsom is going to be one of the
greatest voices to get Joe Biden
reelected and you should mimic
everything he's saying about the current
president
if you want to win do you want to win or
do you want Trump to win that's the
question what do you want what do you
want
because if you want Trump to win start
keep talking [__]
don't be coupled to any kind of reality
and how it actually works
Gavin Newsom is going to be one of the
best campaigners
for Joe Biden that we've gotten
and you should mimic his every single
[__] word in the direction
of defeating Donald Trump
did you notice how I say that you should
use Gavin newsom's words in a way
that would defeat Donald Trump
do you follow me Gavin Newsom did a
magnificent job of it last night
magnificent job
and if you listen to that and you're
like oh well he should be the president
next time in 2024 he should we should
get rid of Biden then you're not paying
attention to the right words
you're not doing it correctly
you're not
Gavin Newsom
played great last night oh my God it was
beautiful but again and I'll show it
hopefully we'll get to a few of those
clips today I don't know it's going to
be a busy [__] day apparently there's
something going on in Miami
I don't know he's supposed to be
arraigned at three
at three Eastern now
um that's an hour after we get off but
it could be delayed because I I guess I
I don't know if he's still looking for
an attorney if they'll finally get one
to come to the courthouse to defend his
dumb ass do you see his [__] post
this morning oh this deranged
[__]
oh my God he election interference what
are you talking about what election the
Republican primary
what are you talking it's dude dude put
on your [__] diaper you need a diaper
change number one number two you're in
the Republican primary man
you're gonna win the primary what are
you talking about election interference
if this election interference and go
blame that on the [__] Republicans
not on Democrats not on Jill Biden
and by the way if if they're going to
keep saying this is political embrace it
folks just lean into it lean into their
narrative who gives a [__] this guy's
making it political in the first place
the only reason why we know any of this
[__] about the Mar-A-Lago
before the indictment hit about the
Mar-A-Lago documents before the
indictment hit was because of Donald
Trump's big [__] mouth
and everything that we've learned from
the special counsel has all been leaks
from Donald Trump not from Jack Smith
they they actually listen to me Donald
Trump
and his team leaked that there was a
tape
and what was on the tape so that way
they could create and spin a narrative
before it dropped in the indictment
that's what happened Jack Smith did not
leak that
they leaked everything
it's it's all it's all to create this
alternative reality it's called manga
have you met them
we act like this isn't this is new what
the [__] is wrong with you people this
isn't new we have video after video
after video at rallies of people
absolutely cult members absolutely being
deranged and delusional into believing
just absolute [__] provable nonsense
but they continue to do it
and they continue to go down this road
that's why I've been telling you that
he's going to win he's going to win he's
going to win he's going to win they
can't beat him
because he's the cult leader and they're
the cult
how how the [__] do they think other
than a cheeseburger getting lodged and
him
passing before he hits the [__] dirt
do they think they're gonna win this
he's not gonna give up he's not going to
give in he's not going to let them
railroad him he needs a pardon he needs
one bad and he needs to Pardon himself
they can't prosecute a sinning president
especially if that sitting president
takes power never gives it back
think about it
they're not going to try him before the
election folks it won't happen I don't
give a [__] what lawyer you see on TV
says oh well it's a rocket docket and
and they're gonna Rim this through and
and it's gonna go to trial by November
no it's not no shut the [__] up stop
listening to The Boob Tube I don't care
if it's CNN MSNBC or wherever stop
listening to these dumb [__] if
you believe someone which I highly
respect until yesterday or the day
before when I seen this this person said
oh it is likely he'll he might go to
jail today you're so full of [__]
[__] Glenn you are full of [__] buddy I
don't care if you're a former Federal
prosecutor they're not going to lock him
up they're not gonna do it folks
and the gag order that everyone's
talking about they might put a gag order
on him but it ain't going to mean [__]
there is a two-tier justice system in
this country folks
there is
and it has protected him his entire
[__] life
his crimes in this case after being
president are so [__] apparent
so glaring
rubbing rubbing rubbing the the the
words Law and Order in his own feces
here literally with the [__]
documents in the bathroom
speaks to a two-tier justice system
he's just committed so much [__]
crime so much apparent crime so
egregious to our national security and
our [__] country that they have to
prosecute him
they don't have a choice
that's why it appears that the two
there's a two-tiered yeses system and
it's against him it's not against him
you stupid Mucka [__]
it's always protected him [__] it's
again it's protecting him this morning
any other [__] trust me any
other [__] would have to drive
their own car to the courthouse get out
of their car walk to the courthouse go
through the [__] process of going
through metal detectors walking in the
courthouse going to the to the U.S
Marshals handing themselves in
and then being put in a [__] cell to
be interviewed by the pre-trial
staff
and then being being arraigned in a
courtroom and taken to a processing room
where they would be fingerprinted DNA
tested or DNA sampled excuse me and have
their [__] photo taken
their passport stripped their rights to
to bear arms you second two a Bros
their ability to [__] leave a
jurisdiction without without permission
every one of us every [__] one of us
would have to do that [__] trust me I
know every [__] one of us
and he's going to be awarded all sorts
of privileges here because he's Trump
he's a rich white man who happened to be
president on a technicality
there is a two-tier justice system manga
your your chest you're just too [__]
delusional to understand that it's
protecting him
you stupid bastards and it's been
protecting him the entire time and it
will continue folks they're gonna let
him run
get it out of your [__] brains that
you're gonna see him in an orange
jumpsuit or handcuffs anytime soon
those those charges those indictments in
Georgia
are not going to be unsealed against
Donald Trump more than likely he may not
even be arraigned in in [__] Georgia
for the time being the other folks in
that indictment may be arraigned
when there is a Federal indictment
when there's a Federal indictment
State prosecutors
lay back that's what happens
they pause their prosecutions
because the federal prosecution always
excused the word trumps the state
prosecution
the prison sentence
the trial
the states always wait
they always wait
the only arraignment that we may see of
Donald Trump is for super senior
indictments in this case or superseding
indictments in the January 6 case
when they bring those charges if
they bring those charges
so I know today's exciting
and today is a day that we should be
thankful for that we get all this
information to politicize and mock manga
but don't get your hopes up if your
hopes are that the prosecutors and the
judge and the U.S Marshals are going to
save our democracy
you're wrong it's us
we are the next jury that Donald Trump
will face
it is us not the jury in in Manhattan
not the not a jury in Georgia not a jury
in D.C
not a jury in Miami or Palm Beach
wherever this jury convenes
the next jury Donald Trump will face is
us we the people
and it is our responsibility
we must be accountable to this
we must engage in our democracy we must
not let this go unchecked
we have to keep going there No One's
Gonna Save Us folks especially from the
fascist
they're not going to save us it is us
who will save us
and we must stay vigilant we must keep
our eyes open and our ears to the ground
we must politicize politicize everything
and every single measure all the way
down the ticket
I have a feeling that this is going to
suppress their vote more than it ever
has more than it did
in the Georgia runoff in 2020 do you
remember that do you remember the
Georgia runoff in 2020 there is likely
to be in an effect here
similar to the Georgia runoff
there is likely to be an effect
similar to that
where people stay at home because they
don't believe the process anymore but
not because of voting machines not
because of support of trump
because they can't support him
and we must draw those wedges we must
encourage that voter suppression oh Tony
you can't say that [__] I can't [__] I
won't
it's our country it's our democracy at
stake here
if they won't vote for Joe Biden by God
state of [__] home
it's time we get serious it's time to
get real
it's time we tell the real [__] truth
here
and the real [__] truth is in some
[__] stupid long shot with Marianne
Williamson our convincing Gavin Newsom
to go against [__] Joe Biden again if
you watch that interview last night and
you think you're going to convince Gavin
Newsom to go against Joe Biden you you
didn't watch the same [__] interview
you truly do have what the right calls
Trump derangement syndrome
[Laughter]
follow his lead
stop listening to delusion
the fact of the matter is this morning
it is apparent
that Donald Trump is going to
Propel this is going to propel him to
the nomination there's no one standing
in his way
no one
even the guy who's pretending to run
against him who is on his payroll Vivek
is down at Mar-A-Lago that's the only
one that's the only one Speaking there's
more who else who else show me the clip
show me where they're taking advantage
of Donald Trump being arraigned they
can't
it's a cult folks it's a cult they can't
take advantage of it they won't take
advantage of it
trust me on this
trust me
or doubt me either way
either way it's your choice
but I'm telling you what is going to
happen here
and don't miss a single [__] minute
of it every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch
and Facebook today is Tuesday how
[__] lucky are we
that arraignment day the second
arraignment day is on a Taco Texas Paul
Tuesday huh
how [__] beautiful is that it's like
the universe just knows I'm sure there's
someone down in Miami who's like you
know what you know when we should do
this arraignment we definitely should do
it on a Tuesday we shouldn't do it on a
Monday we definitely shouldn't do it all
week we should do it on a Tuesday
so that way Tony in Texas Paul can hash
this out this arraignment out
hey Michael
it's free why not why wouldn't you why
you're here subscribe also follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels POD at the Tony
Michaels and that I am at Gabe Sanchez
also you can watch this thing on
Facebook it's there every day just go to
Tony Michaels on Facebook follow me
there you can also watch it on the up
wire the up wire is now out of
suspension they're out of jail
unlike Donald Trump this morning just go
to the upwire.com or search the up wire
on YouTube make sure to follow their
Channel you can view us there as well a
lot of people like to get over on the up
our chat right
another chat that's happening is the
twitch chat go follow us on Twitch
twitch.tv slash D Tony Michaels it's
free to follow us on twitch.tv Tony
Michaels if you want if you want to give
us free monetary support too this is a
great way to do it if you have an Amazon
Prime account you can link that Amazon
Prime account to your Twitch account and
you give us the one free subscription to
Amazon gaming that you get with your
Prime account and we get a couple bucks
each month of Amazon's money it doesn't
cost you a single nickel all you gotta
do is just go in and resubscribe every
month it's kind of a [__] but you know
I'm free money they want you to work for
it a little bit and we want to thank all
the people over there on Twitch and
again if you want to watch on Twitch the
chat is happening over there as well
I got Texas Paul we got Gabe Sanchez oh
man
and this they're begging for pardons
this morning they want pardons baby
don't go anywhere we're gonna talk about
the news in Miami whatever that is
there's something going on in Miami
stick around we'll be right back with
Texas fall right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show no pardons here
today
the back I've been telling you about
this guy running for president he's
pretending to run for president and he's
on it seems to me I mean you know tell
me that you're on drums payroll without
telling me I'm trying to pay you it's
the only guy that's making statements
down at the courthouse today the only
one taking advantage of the political
opportunity what do you know what do you
know the guy's sipping for Trump huh who
would have thought who would have
thought
the other thing that's happening and I
just thought about this just now
imagine this imagine the scene Texas
ball
we're gonna have in this Courthouse
We're not gonna get to see it though Ah
that's the that's the trouble of it is
Donald Trump has to put his first gaze
his first glance
of his arch enemy the guy who's gonna
lock him in prison for a long time Jack
Smith is going to be there in the
courthouse Texas ball
is it going to be there really I hadn't
heard that is he going to be there or is
his lead prosecutor how who in the hell
wouldn't Jack Smith be there no I think
I think there was news last night that
Jack Smith and his team and landed uh in
Miami I don't see that Jack Smith won't
be in the courtroom I doubt Jack Smith
will make statements that'll probably be
his lead team
um but I'm sure Jack Smith wants to be
there in the court in the courtroom
um at least at least you uh put his eyes
and his his nail-biting gaze onto the
Cheeto dust mobster so yeah what's your
take this morning of it
oh man what you're talking about Jack
Smith has some great prosecutors working
for him
um it would surprise me if he actually
steps up and and participates in the
arraignment he's probably if he's there
like you say he is I mean I totally
believe you he uh he's just gonna sit
back there and watch he's gonna just
just sit back there
do you smell that
he's got some really amazing trial
prosecutors working on this that are
going to be they'll be the ones doing
the talking I'm sure but could you could
you imagine what what Donald Trump when
he sits down he said there if he has to
look over and actually see and you know
Jack Trump's going to look at him and go
I mean they just
you won't I know he won't he's super
professional but I would I would
literally cut off 10 years off my life
to actually see to actually see that
happening
ticket price is that the ticket price uh
10 years of your life for that you know
he's losing his mind this morning uh
Texas Paul here's here's him losing his
mind and this was uh I don't know about
15-20 minutes ago he says wait a child
election interference of course I I
tweeted it and said deranged buffoon I
mean this guy just can't quit man he
just he's absolutely he's absolutely a
caged animal here
um and that's and that's the real story
of yesterday when Republicans were right
there's Biden tape 17 recordings like it
okay show them to us and like oh we
don't actually have we don't actually
have the recording we just have someone
saying there's recording get the [__]
out of here man how humiliating is that
man I mean sitting there on Newsmax your
your home field advantage getting the
softballs and just the easiest of easy
questions when are we going to see you
know are are these when are we going to
see these well we don't actually have
these records I mean come on man I mean
Jesus these guys suck at this I I you
know how remember in history you had
like The Teapot Dome and you know you
had all these scandals that they would
just give it a catchy name to I want
them to call this one the bag of dead
Batcher bag of dead Badgers yeah because
the Republicans keep coming up and
saying that's the clip you're referring
to right
yeah yeah this is a news I'll play it go
ahead go ahead I just want to make sure
when they write the history books I
really want them to call this the bag of
dead Badgers because the Republicans
like every time there's breaking news
run to a microphone and tell you about
this just all right we got this thing
all right it's the end of it and then
you open the bag and there's nothing but
a dead badger in there you know what I
mean
and it stinks to eye Heaven here's
here's Jim Comer he couldn't even work
up the course to tell him the truth that
they don't actually there's not action
recordings they just have someone saying
those recordings they're not an actual
recordings
um but here's here's the clip you're
referring to on Newsmax when will you be
able to confirm if these recordings are
legit how long is that going to take
well I can confirm that the recordings
were in the 1023 remember I was with
Senator Grassley when we saw the
unredacted version okay so Chris
Grassley was saying alleged yesterday so
these recordings are legit you can
confirm they are legitimate they were I
can confirm they were listed in the 1023
that the FBI redacted we don't know if
they're legit or not but we know that
the foreign National claims he has them
narrator says they are not legit they
are not legit
I said come on man this is all [__]
nonsense right like like even the
reporters like look man if you got them
say you got them if you verify them say
you verify them but you know I said this
in the a block and I know you were
listening a little bit is that they
always give away their game right they
always they always give away their play
because they're like oh we're gonna say
that that the Democrats are making this
political move while we make this
political move and what I mean by that
is last week when um the transcripts
of trump came out in the indictment
right it was confirmed in the indictment
that yes he really did say I can't I
didn't classify declassify these things
and I can't because I'm not the
president anymore here you not even
supposed to look at this classified
information I'm not supposed to be
showing you like he says it in the
transcript and the first reaction to the
right wing on Twitter and online was oh
that has to be AI that has to be they
can't be real recordings and now and now
here they are the day that Trump's
getting rained the night before Trump's
getting rain they get [__] Chuck
Grassley to go out and absolutely
[__] humiliate and embarrass himself
on the senate floor spewing this
absolute nonsense about some
whistleblower report that didn't even
that is that was investigated by the FBI
and wasn't [__] it was shown not to
be real
this is all [__] all of it the whole
lot of it
Tony you've got to just remind the
audience
who were these tapes given to
who sat on these who looked into this
investigated it and just I guess decided
it wasn't important enough to go after
Joe [__] bill Barr no yes
Paul don't don't confuse people with
facts don't get Maga all confused with
facts okay that would be that would that
would make that would make it to where
they couldn't spend their lives
appropriately right and that's and
that's the rub about this is that Chuck
Grassley knows this that's why last
night within like I don't know 15 20
seconds of him saying this stupid [__]
these stupid lies on the floor of the
Senate he had to say alleged like 14
times and the reason why is to protect
his own ass and he knows it because it's
a [__] lie when they say allegedly
allegedly allegedly allegedly allegedly
when it's a 10-23 form that was filed by
Rudy Giuliani found to be [__] like
you said by Bill Barr this is all
nonsense this is all [__] nonsense
this is all [__] and they know it
but they don't care
you know if you sit down with an FBI any
special agent they have got to fill out
one of these forms this is what they're
referring to this is not evidence this
is not anything this is just a special
agent saying yeah I said that with this
guy who did an interview on Biden and
this that and the other and he said that
he had a 37 inch penis and that's going
to be in the damn form right it's going
to be it doesn't mean the guy has a 37
inch penis it just means that he said he
did right and they did the investigation
this was in Bill Barr's hands they did
not give Biden I promise you people they
did not look at this and give Joe Biden
a pass they didn't okay if they had
something there I mean Bill Barr has
come out and said this is this is
[__] I mean this is just he he said
it himself I mean come on people I mean
you can say anything to an FBI agent and
get it into the notes I mean you can
well you can see it just came on TV you
can say anything on TV apparently
um I'm going to show you a clip of Byron
Donald's absolutely making a fool out of
himself this morning and acting as if he
knows about Mar-A-Lago and the security
of the bathrooms in Mar-A-Lago this is
really [__] dumb as we as we uh as
the American public have now seen where
Donald Trump was storing the [__]
documents in a goddamn bathroom Byron
Donald's just trying to convince us this
morning that hey man the bathrooms are
secure at Mar-A-Lago it's a bathroom you
can't just walk in a bathroom let's
listen on this one other point I want to
make you guys are throwing up the
pictures about they were in the bathroom
where they were on the stage it's
somebody who's been to Mar-A-Lago you
just can't walk through Mar-A-Lago of
your own accord that's not true that's
not what the indictment says that's not
what they found you [__] chucklehead
let's continue with the chuckle [__]
though because Secret Service is all
over the place secret service is not in
charge of protecting documents they're
in charge of protecting Trump they're
not in charge of securing documents
they're in charge of securing the
[__] ex-president that twice impeach
now federally indicted and state
indicted in the state of New York on how
many felonies is now at 60 some 60
something no it's 70 some felonies so if
the documents are in a place they're in
a room depending on the time of year you
can't even get into Central oh there are
33 000. oh well Texas ball depending on
the time of year I mean sometimes time
during that time of year you don't have
to take a [__] sometimes you do so it
just depends on what time of year it is
that you would be allowed to go in the
bathroom or all the top secret documents
were placed
well you know that they they busted a a
Chinese spider by the name of Eugene
Zhang you
you with your best again
you know she
had phones uh five different SIM cards a
pile of cash she had a device to detect
to detect hidden cameras I bet she had a
lock you know I can actually pick a lock
toning I can't I can get through one of
those old pieces Hey Hey listen any any
bathroom that you run into that has a
lock on both sides you there's no way
you're going to be able to pick that
have you ever seen a bathroom with a
lock on both sides have you ever seen
that no I'm serious think about this
Kevin McCarthy was saying this this
morning that somehow they were secure
because a bathroom door can be locked
you lock the bathroom door from the
[__] inside you you dummy you [__]
ridiculous I have
I have new you know I you know I built
this house just a few years ago okay I
have brand new state-of-the-art
locks knobs on my door I can get through
one with this this comes with every one
of them you're talking about what you're
talking about is the bathroom door you
lock it and then you close it when you
walk out right so it's locked is that
what you're saying but there's a little
hole that you just put a paper clip in
and then you it just it pops the lock
yeah it's not it's not a lock for
security it's a lock for privacy you
[__] buffoon Kevin McCarthy and bro
Byron Donald's people are [__] idiots
how in the hell can Maca be this stupid
they can't be the stupid you know what
it has to be they have to have cognitive
dissidents that's what it has to be
that's all this is is cognitive
dissonance all the way down that's why
he's going to win let me show you a clip
here's CNN yesterday interviewing some
of these [__] weirdos about Trump's
indictment and if you're not if you're
still wondering if he's gonna win I'll
give you this as evidence inside the
State Convention his support orders are
unfazed I think it's a bunch of bulls
Trump ain't then that wrong thing Trump
then they saved this country they're not
gonna let it stop they can't stand the
fact that he's running for president and
I am a Donald Trump fan it's uh probably
altered but it's just typical typical uh
liberal propaganda none of the
Republican voters CNN spoke with had
read the indictment no I wouldn't waste
my time on the phone in that I don't
care about the adaptment that you could
hey you could indict a baloney sandwich
you can indict a baloney sandwich Texas
fall this guy's this guy this guy is so
[__] delusional he doesn't even know
that there's ham out there he went
straight for baloney
oh my God what do you got Tony can I can
I have 20 seconds go ahead 20 seconds
yeah go ahead this is the indictment I
have really see the clerk stamp this is
the indictment okay
section three the classified documents
Trump stored in his boxes included
information regarding defense and
weapons capabilities of both the United
States and foreign countries United
States nuclear programs potential
vulnerabilities of the United States and
its allies and to military attack and
plans for possible retaliation in
response to a foreign attack the
unauthorized disclosure of these
classified documents could put at-risk
National Security of the United States
foreign relations
ran out of brass the safety of the
United States military and human sources
and yada yada yada okay that's section
three
page two
read the freaking indictment read
extreme
it's in PDF read the indictment the
reason why they're not going to read the
indictment is because they can't read
the indictment and and I I mean they
can't maybe read but they can't read it
because if they do read it and they do
believe it what I'm I'm top hey do you
think do you think some of these
[__] would have trouble reading
a Federal indictment look at these
here's this lady here this is this
statement from her is perfect this is
why this is why he's going to win listen
to what how she described Trump listen
not gonna let it stop they can't stand
the fact that he's running for president
and I am a Donald Trump fan and I am a
Donald Trump fan this is professional
wrestling folks
I I say this all the time we are at the
intersection of WrestleMania and real
life and the Donald Trump [__] Flag
Store is on one corner the Q Anon store
is on the other Corner okay that's just
the way it is that's the reality that we
[__] live in it's a q Anon World
we're just living in it folks when she
says I'm a Donald Trump fan I'm a Donald
Trump fan that's how she is that's how
she is engaging in her political
activity is she's a fan of Donald Trump
so if you're still standing around
wondering how he's gonna win and why
he's going to win and Ron DeSantis man
if if you have any kind of [__]
chance you better get out in front of a
microphone today man today and start
attacking Trump on this like now like
right like yesterday maybe last week
when I uh two weeks ago when I told you
to keep attacking him on this but you
won't because you're a coward Jesus
I'm telling you man I am Telling You
DeSantis is hoping that we take him down
and he doesn't have to get his hands
dirty so he doesn't have a pissed off
Trump base out there he is terrified to
say a word about Donald Trump just well
terrifying that's a good point about
taking Donald Trump down and it's a
point I made I've been making for a long
time uh people even close to me the
other day were saying yeah but someone
on MSNBC said it's a rocket Dock and
then it could possibly go to trial I'm
like that's delusional it's not you're
it's not going to go to trace not he is
not well he could be indicted in Georgia
he's not going to go to trial in Georgia
it's he's not going to go to trial in
New York let me show you let me show you
on pod says America
yeah I I can't help but attack them I'm
sorry they're [__] political Elites
and and they talk down to people in this
country and that kind of pisses me off
um they don't do their job appropriately
as I see it but you know that's just my
[__] opinion it's the actual right
thing but it's just my opinion but here
is here's pawn saves America and they're
interviewing tis James if you don't know
tits James is the New York attorney
general she has a civil case against
Donald Trump she's also the attorney
general who is in charge of uh the state
law enforcement where the Manhattan D.A
is charging Trump with 34 felonies a
business fraud in the state of New York
on those State charges but here she is
listen to what she says listen to the
hint that she gives you about what
Donald When Donald Trump could go to
trial and who's going to take him to
trial first the special counsel has
asked for a speedy trial for this is is
this going to intersect with your case
at all how is everybody going to manage
the calendar here so in all likelihood I
believe that my case as well as D.A
Bragg and
um the Georgia case
um will unfortunately have to be
adjourned pending the outcome of the
federal case so it all depends upon uh
the scheduling of this particular case I
know there's going to be a flood a
flurry of motions motions to dismiss
Discovery issues all of that so it
really all depends obviously all of us
want to know what this judge judge
Kennedy is going to do and whether or
not she's going to delay this particular
case are you concerned about that um I
think everyone is concerned about that
um so obviously it will depend upon the
scheduling the special she's giving you
a hint here Texas Paul you know what
she's saying here's what she's saying is
that judge Cannon is definitely going to
delay this case she's going to favor
Donald Trump on delaying this case he's
going to delay it it's going to delay
all the state prosecution it's it's
going to delay the trials he won't see a
[__] jury until after in a courtroom
until after this election we are his
jury and we need to start acting like it
we need to stop acting like the justice
system is going to save our democracy
here that is not the intent of the
justice system folks the justice system
intent was never to save our democracy
it's us it's the ballot it's the vote
it's us engaging in our Democratic
constitutional republic that will save
it
I'm telling you she's telling you out
loud or trying to hint T out loud what
I've been saying just right out that he
is not going to see a jury in a
courtroom and a trial until after this
election Am I Wrong Texas Paul tell me
I'm wrong please tell me I'm wrong
well you're not wrong about some of it
to be honest with you there are cases
that you're not going to see for
instance the January when when
back in November of what was it 2021
when when Jack Smith was first put on
the job
he was charged with investigating two
separate things one was the documents
case and the other was January 6th no
you are not going to see January 6
indictments till late maybe next summer
this time next summer July August of
next summer you're just not because
you've got the uh the case down in
Georgia which will come probably
the indictments will come probably late
August but you won't see a a case till
now nothing will see a courtroom until
late this year they'll delay it over the
holidays you won't really get into that
until until next year but this documents
case I I've got to tell you I have
been sitting back watching Jack Smith
and I heard everybody tell me this this
some bitch's greatest thing since sliced
bread and I'm like I ain't seen nothing
yet you know this move that he did Tony
was freaking brilliant
he didn't put the full case out there I
mean there's only seven I got you know
all seven of the Chargers right here
he did not put everything out he could
you know you know there could be
superseding indictments and yada yada
yada which is likely to rope more people
into this like they roped uh Walt Mata
or mata mata NADA whatever whatever his
[__] name is his valet they wrote him
in right and and there's likely to be
more superseding indictments even in
this documents case to maybe rope some
more in go ahead sorry
but yeah no this is just super simple
straightforward stuff that even you know
if Island Cannon does try to throw
wrenches into the works the 11th circuit
is ready to remove her the minute she
screws up I mean
you know she's arrogant I don't see her
voluntarily stepping down but if she
does try to do something ridiculous like
she did in the original case where she
was slapped down so hard they told her
you know I mean you never hear them tell
another judge you didn't even have
jurisdiction to rule in this case much
less what you did you know I mean they
humiliated her in print they are waiting
for her to screw up so no I think Jack
Smith did a brilliant thing he went with
a super simple case super
straightforward
all you have to do is say here's the
document
here's the text conversation where he
knew he had it these were the three
tries we gave him to return it this was
his response done
we're out
defend yourself if you can I mean that
this so Tina points out here on Facebook
she says listen to Jack speedy trial
what I want you to when I want to tell
the audience is this
and this is from personal experience the
defendant has the right to a speedy
trial not the prosecution the
prosecution does not have the right to a
speedy trial it is the defendant that
has the right to speed draw so it
doesn't matter what the government or
the prosecutors want as far as speedy
trial judge Cannon has a lot a lot of
say on how to delay this case and she
has a lot of leeway to delay this case
so I understand that Jack Smith wants a
speedy trial the prosecutors the
government we the people want a speedy
trial but Donald Trump has the right to
a speedy trial he also has the right to
waive a speedy trial and that is the key
here is that Donald Trump is going to
most definitely pile on just like tis
Jane says and she's giving you the hint
folks
she's giving you the hint that she he is
they are going to pile on and pile on
and pile on dumb [__] motions that
will delay this and give Eileen Cannon
our uh is it Eileen or Aileen anyways
judge Cannon the leeway to appear to not
be uh partial to this defendant and
delaying him the speedy trial is not the
right of the governments it is the right
of the defendant you as a citizen as a
person who can be prosecuted by the
government have a right to a speedy
trial it is your constitutional right
not the government's right to a speedy
trial so remember that when you keep if
you hear that Jack Smith wants a speedy
trial he may want it that doesn't mean
he's going to get it and I agree with
you Texas ball that Canon has to be very
careful here and she's probably going to
lean on her clerks a lot
um in this case and the reason why is
because not only does she not want to be
removed from this case by the 11th
circuit she doesn't want her credit
ability to be embarrassed anymore than
it already is which it's really she
doesn't have any credibility left as far
as a lot of people are concerned here
just because of the way she ruled on the
special master and the documents already
a lot of people would say that she
should recuse herself because of that
but it's likely she won't because she is
a trump scumbag and but my guess is if
she wants to continue to be a federal
judge after this case or during this
case she's going to lean heavily on her
clerks and those clerks are going to do
the research and they're going to do the
research of how best to make sure that
she can stay the judge on this case but
help Donald Trump to delay this case
past the election I believe that's going
to be true I believe that's the best
help she's going to be able to give
Donald Trump that's the that's the
farthest she's going to be able to go I
think and that's what she's going to do
she's already shown she is willing to
help Donald Trump in that respect
everything you said is 100 True the only
thing that I would throw out there on
top of that to give people some some you
know something to hold on to here is is
just a couple things one the government
presents its case
you defend yourself the government will
dictate how fast that case comes out if
Eileen Cannon tries to interfere with
how quickly the government tries to put
its case out there she has already
received a phone call
from far more experienced judges on in
the 11th circuit that said we will Fast
Track
any
appeal by the government so you will not
get your month-long delay for every
ruling that you put out there you will
get a week
to prepare that's it that phone call has
already been made she they have told her
you are screwed you if you mess with
this you're done we we will expedite
these hearings nobody's allowing Donald
Trump to to just try to throw a blizzard
worth of paperwork out there and and and
and and and slow this down the
government will dictate how fast this
case comes out now the defense
absolutely they can slow roll all they
want they can talk as slow as they want
to and take as much time as they're
entitled to their defense they are
but again
if it starts to get ridiculous the the
prosecution does have the ability to
object I mean they can I mean right I I
agree with you but but here's here's the
here's the the problem
um that that is that is gonna come about
and what I want is the is is the people
the people who are going to be deciding
the future of the country next year
to know that again do not count do not
count on Jack Smith or the government or
the prosecutors saving you from Donald
Trump it's not going to happen and and
Lisa says she agrees with Texas Paul I
also agree with Texas Paul but I also
have experience in this Arena and let me
tell you something let me tell you
something the the courts are going to
give the defendant a lot of leeway and
the courts and that's that is how it
[__] works you are innocent until
proven guilty that is how they have to
operate in this court and they give and
Donald Trump's going to use every single
[__] tactic that he can he's using
the tactic today I mean I mocked him
earlier that he doesn't have an attorney
for this arraignment he doesn't have an
attorney for this arraignment and that's
on purpose folks that's on purpose he
wants to try to go into this courtroom
and he wants to try to make sure that
he's not arraigned today so he can walk
out of the courtroom saying they didn't
even irate me so I'm not even I'm not
even charged I'm telling you I'm telling
you think I'm [__] crazy but I'm
telling you this is a tactic by him he's
a lunatic
and he will say breaking news go ahead
there's been some breaking breaking news
on that he had an attorney by the name
of Chris Christ he's a former solicitor
general of Florida he's worked some
really big cases he was working on on uh
Trump's January 6th defense and he
refused to get involved with the
documents case because you know Boris
Epstein
the russian-born guy that's just he's
been married to Trump this whole time
every time you see Trump in a court case
you've got Boris Epstein there he was at
his indictment in Manhattan he was
walking through the door with him
um he was interfering with Chris kise
and Chris Kai said I will not be
involved in this documents case
so everybody thought okay he's out he
agreed to show up this morning for the
arraignment so he's got an attorney for
the arraignment it just will not be his
attorney that takes him through trial
same with with uh Todd Blanche up in
Manhattan is that attorney
um does he have does he have authority
in the southern district of Florida
well because that's that's what that's
the the problem here is that there has
to be an attorney who has the ability to
represent him in that Florida courthouse
is the problem now again the only thing
the only thing that they have to do is
to basically um waive his right to read
the indictment in the courtroom and they
may not waive it they may make the judge
read the whole [__] thing who knows
they may but it wave is right to the to
the indictment um also uh indicate that
yes he the client does understand the
indictment the client has looked at the
indictment and that's the waving of it
they do fully understand what the
indictment says and they understand what
the case that the prosecutors are making
against him and then he'll they'll plea
I mean literally this arraignment from
the beginning that they gavel until they
gavel out May last 10 to 15 minutes
especially if they waive the right to
read the indictment now the the thing is
is that this arraignment is only to to
deliver the charges to Donald Trump and
his legal team that's it that's all it's
designed to do there's going to be no
other proceeding today other than the
judge verifying that Donald Trump has
this arraignment now the thing that is
weird here Texas poll and I mentioned
this in the a block the thing that's
very weird is normally when there's a
federal defendant who is being charged
with felonies on the Espionage Act
normally normally they stay in custody
he is not going to remain in custody
this morning that it's not going to
happen that is going to be the thing
that he that is the privilege that he
has afforded
because you I mean wouldn't you just
love it though if Joe
listen if I'm wrong if I'm wrong that
would be fantastic and the judge could
no you're not wrong I'm not wrong you're
not wrong that would be great if I was
wrong trust me there's nothing more that
I want than this [__] to sit in
a prison cell or a jail cell and run for
run for prison and win the nomination in
a jail cell for the Republican Party
trust me he would do it it would happen
but that's not what's gonna happen
they're gonna yeah but you know and you
were right in what you were saying Trump
actually has no legal team to represent
him in this trial he doesn't Chris
Christ is doing him a favor that's it he
paid Chris kyce three million bucks to
defend him on the January 6th and that's
it that was just a favor to get him
through today that's it Chris Christ is
not his attorney
you're absolutely right about that look
at what he's facing though Tony and
they're like well we're they're going to
PR this guy
they're going to send him out on
personal recognitions right you know
that's insane this guy is is is as old
as he is is facing these indictments
he's facing the indictments in Manhattan
next you know he will face more
indictments down in Georgia near the end
of the summer
uh you got finally Willis has already
notified law enforcement be ready Late
July there's going to be some crazy [__]
down here in Georgia she's already put
him on notice then you've got
we haven't even seen the January 6
indictments from Jack Smith he's still
investigating that Tony right I mean
this guy's going to spend the rest of
his natural life even like you said he's
not going to jail he's not going to jail
because he will appeal when he loses and
he will lose when he loses this case
he's not going to get sentenced he's
going to appeal right I mean they will
drag this out you're absolutely 100 spot
on Tony you are but think about it think
about his Flight Risk
just just consider that for a minute
this guy has a jet that if you fuel that
damn thing up a hundred percent
he doesn't have to put wheels down until
he reaches ratchet
he can go around the globe in that plane
without refueling
well I wonder who's facing the rest of
his life I want to say that we have a a
record audience here there's a lot of
people tuning in there's thousands of
people tuning in all across where we're
streaming today and a lot of people are
saying that I'm dark or that there's a
dark mood in the chat folks I'm being
realistic here I'm telling you the
[__] truth I'm telling you what to
expect you can be excited listen we're
gonna have so much information to
politicize over the coming months not
just in this indictment but what's Texas
Paul is saying possibly a Georgia
indictment it is likely that that opens
the floodgates to investigations in
Arizona Pennsylvania Michigan Wisconsin
into the fake collector scheme we're
going to get the January six indictments
probably sometime next year because Jack
Smith is not just going to indict Trump
in that case I mean there's there's
Eastman there's there's uh Scott Perry
the congressman there's other Congress
people that may be involved into playing
January 6th there's Steve Bannon there's
Roger Stone that are possible targets
there's going to be a lot to politicize
about Republicans and not only that
there's going to be a lot of wedges to
to wedge down into their primary because
that's the real election cycle cycle
that we're in is the Republican primary
we got to remember that so we as we as a
a a country we have to gauge in our
democracy in the cycle that we're in we
have to engage in the Republican primary
and that's going to be fun oh my God is
that going to be fun we are going to
Mock and laugh and have so much fun with
these pieces of garbage over the next
eight nine ten months in this primary
and beyond that into the general
election it is going to be fantastic
folks it is going to be all kinds of fun
but I'm not telling you this stuff
uh we lost Texas ball he'll probably be
back he must have lost connection I'm
not telling you this stuff to make it
dark I'm not telling you this stuff to
bring you down I'm trying to give you a
realistic thing that's gonna happen
the real the reality is the reality is
is that Donald Trump will not see a
trial you better come to grips with that
if he does see a trial if he does see a
trial fantastic I welcome him seeing a
trial Texas Paul I I welcome him seeing
a trial but I don't think it's going to
happen realistically now I do want to
move on to the election because I want
to get to one person who's trying to
land punches on Donald Trump but they're
just not Landing Texas ball they're just
not Landing I really I had High Hopes I
had high hopes for Chris Christie I
really did I had high hopes for Chris
Christie I really thought like he would
come out and just [__] beat the ever
loving [__] out of him but he's kind of
soft ending him he's kind of something
here he is um in his um in his town hall
with Anderson Cooper trying to attack
Donald Trump and I don't think it's very
successful let's watch his employees
were scared they was called his boxes
his boxes he wants his boxes near him he
flew the boxes up to New Jersey for
summer vacation what is this like
they're a family member I mean seriously
I gotta have my boxes with me okay well
first off Chris Christie I think it's a
little too early to be talking about um
vacation in Jersey after you were
spotted uh with you and your family
after you shut the beaches down and
you're the only one on the beach I think
it's a little early for you to be
criticizing people on vacations in New
Jersey uh but you know this is such a
soft-handed punch Texas fault what a
what a [__] [__] holy [__] Chris
Christie dude if you're gonna swing at
him [__] swing and hit him what are
you doing and Chris Christie is one of
the best at this I don't know why he he
can't accomplish this he's he's being
way too careful don't you think yeah and
Aaron rupar pointed it out I had totally
missed it you know I've been watching
this and I totally missed it he didn't
get a single line of Applause until he
talked about well if I win I'll make the
food better in the white house because I
I'm Italian
that was the
first Applause I mean he kept I mean he
was swinging his ass off and that entire
audience was like why are you saying
this about Donald Trump you're right
right Donald Trump right right you sound
like a Democrat
[Laughter]
I mean really honestly if Chris Christie
wants to get into a primary he should
switch parties at this point don't you
think like he would be much more
effective not welcome he's not welcome
he can [__] off Kenny well let's let
maybe he throws a punch here Texas Paul
maybe I'm I'm not playing the whole clip
and he doesn't throw a he doesn't you
know maybe I'm just got to the punch
that he's really trying to land here
let's let's see let's on the bright side
if he did as you said run as a Democrat
he might eat Robert Kennedy Jr so you
know
like like on like on a hoagie bun or
something
okay well look at him he might let's
let's continue let me ask you a question
what exactly was he doing with them
did someone remind him he's not the
president anymore you don't need these
things anymore this is Vanity run amok
Anderson run of muck ego Runner muck
vanity run amok dude that's such weak
sauce you are such a goddamn [__] man I
had again I had way more High Hopes two
or three weeks ago for Chris Christie I
was like oh man get him getting in the
race man I really think he's gonna
[__] just blast this guy he's gonna
burn him to the ground pour gasoline on
it [__] no this guy isn't even using
lighter fluid he's trying to he's trying
to like he's trying to light this with a
foot Striker man what are you doing
Chris Christie get with it man dump
gasoline on this fire and burn him to
the ground and piss on his ashes why
isn't he doing that Texas Paul why and
it's so rehearsed too don't you think
he's trying he is he's trying he really
you got to give him at least he's trying
I mean it's not that same [__] that you
reserve for screaming at reporters and
[__] right you know that's what I
expected from Chris Christie's the old
Chris Christie governor Chris Christie
where he's like [__] you and your mom
too like that kind of [__] you know what
I mean just just no holds bar but this
is so rehearsed shut up shut up I'm
talking and I'm the governor yeah we
were hoping for that Chris Christie and
we got
um rehearsed Chris Christie I mean
literally
I'll run them up here on a Mac it feels
like it feels like he practiced that
[__] in front of a mirror for at least
three days and doesn't believe that it's
gonna work at all like he doesn't even
believe that this [__] argument
vanity run amok get the [__] Addy what
are you talking about you're talking to
manga and you're saying vanity run amok
who are you trying to court here what
the [__] okay let's finish up because I
want to give Chris Christie you know
again a chance to really land one here
let's see and he is now gonna put this
country through this
when we didn't have to go through it
everyone's blaming the prosecutors
he did it it's his conduct you know him
what a week week punch
and it's not he didn't even really swing
to be quite honest that that's the best
he had that's the best he had really and
you know up in New Hampshire you had had
DeSantis up there he was watching this
while he was on the campaign Trail
sitting there eating his pudding cup
[Laughter]
[__] about Trump I don't give a damn
what Tony Michael says I ain't coming
out again
listen Ronnie Ronnie honestly if you
want to win this thing if you truly want
to win it actually I I'm starting to
believe that you don't want to win it
but if you do want to win it your best I
I think that you want to run against
Gavin Newsom in 2028 is what I think
um that you're that you're put the hand
that you're playing here but it ain't
gonna work Trump's going to ruin your
political career if you stay in this
race or you don't get in it one or the
other
um so get in it fight fight and maybe
the Republican party will respect you in
2020 and you'll get to run again so I
can Gavin Newsom maybe you will I really
hope you've got I really hope you got
those Gavin Newsom Clips
we're going to get to it but I want to
go to someone who who is so in support
of Donald Trump not Chris Christie who's
fake trying to land a punch on Donald
Trump here's this guy I don't know who
this guy is but um
holy [__]
I do I'm telling you this is [__]
wild [__] man these these megalodites
do you do you think in any [__]
reality that Donald Trump would come up
to this guy and listen to anything
anything I mean absolutely anything just
one sentence a couple words that this
guy would have to say the way he looks
do you think that no [__] way no
Donald Trump would look down on this guy
and think he's some kind of scum scuzzy
bastard right wouldn't come on a
thousand miles of this [__]
I saw a tweet that was perfect about
this guy he said you know
when Donald Trump was committing these
crimes this guy was stacking amplifiers
and speakers together at a warrant
concert you know
now he's sitting here I'm in between
yeah
oh my God you know what's funny is this
guy claims in this clip to be a federal
agent for years for years I'm like dude
there's a difference between an agent
and an informant but let's let's take a
listen to this guy
a lot of my family blood spilled for
this country I'm not gonna let it go to
waste I'm not I refuse I did 19 years
here as a federal agent in Dade County
um
I'm just not going to let this country
go to waste and right now it's going to
waste well if he gets indoctrinated
January 6th did you hear that Texas
Vault that's how I know he's not a
federal agent he said when he gets
indoctrinated this guy is supposed to be
a federal agent for 19 years and doesn't
know the difference between
indoctrinated and indicted give me a
[__] break come on man
he doesn't know the guy running the
Sorting machine down at the post office
isn't a federal agent man I mean
running the Sorting machine
this guy running the Sorting machine
though I don't even know if they trust
him let's keep listening in gonna look
like a playground
it's going to look like a playground
from the inside voices that I hear from
all the militias and everything else
it's going to be a playground but if
they want to fight bring it I mean I've
been in I watch Kamala Harris in Orlando
I watched antifa throw bottles spit on
my child
throw stuff at us they told us to
refrain ourselves really okay
but it is what it is you know this
country's so left right now but we got
to bring it back to the right we got to
get right on the right path we got to
bring everything back if we don't we're
going to crumble we're going to be a
third world nation you know you you
bring a good point with this morning
this may be Junior's dealer maybe that's
who this is maybe that's why he's so
loyal I know I'm serious I'm serious he
was a he was a federal informant for 19
years so that way he wasn't
indoctrinated by the federal persecutors
and um and he's he's he's got he's got a
package for Donald Trump Jr you know
every single week I would say that maybe
what this guy is now there's another a
couple other clips of these [__]
boneheads
um this morning and one of them is
caring I'm not [__] you they're
carrying like a hog head on us on a
stake have you seen this one what the
hell was that all about I I don't know
this is some weird [__] let's see if I
can find it I really couldn't figure it
out what's his message I mean
I'm not really sure I don't know let me
see if I can find it here uh of the guy
here he is here's the video uh I'm not
gonna play the sound because it doesn't
really the sound doesn't give you much
more effect than just the video but here
here's this guy
um desecrating the American Flag by
draping it over him like that and you
can see here
heat shoving it in a dead Pig's mouth
yeah yeah well right and then he's got a
a real Pig's head on on a steak here
this is [__] weird as [__] I mean
really honestly the audio it doesn't
matter but it feels like to me the audio
should be like down down
[Music]
that's my best uh mouth banjo but this
is this is dueling banjo's I guarantee
you yeah you got a pretty mouth I mean
that's literally what I think of when I
see this guy and he looks like he could
be the brother of the other guy really
honestly I mean they could be brothers
for for you know and and you know to be
fair here but again these people always
yell and scream about desperating the
flag he's wearing the flag he's draping
the flag over him uh which is not a flag
code I would imagine oh here's another
here's another story you see that the
blacks for Trump showed up
you see that
um that was trending on on um on Twitter
too let me show you let me show you some
other supporters the blacks for Trump uh
here if I can find it let's see
um it's you'll you'll be uh surprised uh
to see this
but um um here's here's a couple uh
supporters and they're blacks for Trump
I don't know if her name is like Martha
black and Diana black but um they're the
blacks they're the blacks for Trump what
what I mean they're not
why are you laughing I'm telling you if
they're flex your trumpet ain't because
they're black right Am I Wrong well my
[__]
um
you know what this reminds me of it
reminds me of of Donald's out there
talking about well you just can't walk
around Mar-A-Lago they won't just let
you walk no down
they will not let you walk around
marlaco I can walk around anywhere that
I want right you can't and there's a
reason why because there are a bunch of
racist ass bastards that's why
I just
this right here is just freaking
hilarious man I mean hilarious you talk
about having all the self you know
awareness of a dog licking its own butt
in the middle of a street you know I
mean these people just have no freaking
clue
I mean look at these two
of course uh well again you know these
the the people black for Trump which is
a joke
um show up at they show up at these
these events and they pass out these
t-shirts
um because it's Daniel again they think
if white people walk around wearing
shirts that say blacks for Trump that
that means that there's there's people
in this country who are black to support
Donald Trump which of course there is I
mean Jesus Christ no there's a lot of
people that vote and and have political
uh uh support against their own interest
that's that's clear I mean just look at
Lindsey Graham and Tim Scott just the
senators from South Carolina for crying
out loud
um but the thing is is that this is
their remote this is their this is the
propagating of this idea that oh yeah
there's blacks or Trump and there's
white people that know there's blacks
for Trump okay yeah that's that's what
it is well let's go on to um the only
thing wider than that would have been if
you'd had Candace Owens wearing that
shirt
oh my God oh my God so there was a bomb
threat uh already uh down there in Miami
apparently
um near where the Press was at now
that's the thing uh uh Laura Loomer you
know that [__] nut job she's nuttier
than the [__] squirrel turd I mean
not even a squirtle I'm in some of these
Twitter spaces with her oh my my God she
never shuts the hell up and that's all
she's just [__] nonsense you mean
she's not still chained to that door
well I'm gonna I'm gonna show you a
video I'm gonna show you a video of her
walking around showing that everyone
down there at the courthouse was
basically media
um and that's apparently where this bomb
threat was uh waged and then they found
a suspicious package now I'm gonna mute
this but here is um here's uh where they
had courted off the uh the area around
the suspicious bag or package whatever
it was and they're just making sure that
wasn't I want to point this out
this sign here right here where and you
see all these tents in the background
those are media tents
in the background it says uh [__] the
Communist controlled news media because
this is like the this is like the news
media camp and that's where the bomb
threat was they moved the media across
the street and out of the area uh to to
make sure that there wasn't an actual
bomb uh in the area someone needs to
check where Marjorie Taylor green is by
the way uh I just are where she was last
night but I I just think this is funny
the [__] the Communist controlled news
media
um and they called in a bomb threat of
course I wonder if it was the same
person who put the sign up who did this
bomb or the person Marjorie Taylor green
who is the pipe bomber in DC but this is
uh this is the sign of everyone trying
to push the media back trying to push
the crowd back from the area where the
bomb threat is now I don't actually
think they found the bomb it was just a
threat of course they're terrorists
um and they're they're stupid buffoon
terrorists they're Maga what else do you
want from them but um that was the scene
there down there in Miami as the media
had to move because there's no Trump
supporters I mean there's tens of them
Texas Paul there's tens of them uh a
news media down there let me show you
the um the video
that Laura Loomer posted and I know
everyone's super interested in what she
has to what her take out oh yeah
okay I get how could I get through my
day without knowing what Laura Loomer
thinks I mean
here is here's her with her cell phone
she's a great reporter here you see up
you see all the news media here and with
their legitimate uh equipment and stuff
ready to report on the news these are
these are local news reporters national
news reporters and international news
reporters and she's walking around with
her cell phone notice how many notice
how many are media and how many are
actual uh moglodytes uh in this in this
little video here
so I'm here in front of the
president Trump is scheduled to be
arranged as you can see people are
starting to pull in
there's
tons of media here ever seen so many
media tense
she's like I've never seen so many media
attends that one of the biggest news
events of all time because president
Trump a former ex-president is going to
be arraigned on 37 Federal felonies
under the Espionage Act well not all of
them but most of them are under the
Espionage Act what are you talking about
you [__] idiot corsair's a shitload
of media I what why wouldn't there be
let's let's continue again you see the
one guy in front of her there's a few
Red Hats of course they're feds Texas
Paul I'm sure they're feds is they're
undercover feds
a lot of people
president Trump is supposed to be here
around two o'clock for a 3 P.M
arraignment
and we'll be on the stream all day long
I'm gonna have a live feed streaming
from my Twitter soon but that Grandma
Swami is scheduled to have a press
conference at 10 30 Eastern so there she
mentions vivec having a press conference
I got a clip of that too and I got a lot
to say about fabex little thing what do
you what do you make of a nut job there
walking around the sidewalk walking
through the Press pointing out that look
there's a lot of press in this event
more pressed than I've ever seen before
yeah no [__] Sherlock
what an idiot
you're about to see the president former
president of the United
federal charges for our
new
I think you're I think your audio is
cutting out you may have to go off and
go back on I'm not sure
you may I think you're Frozen let's um
okay so I want to go to the Vivek thing
while Texas Paul gets his uh his stuff
going so uh Laura Loomer pointing out
the Vivek
um was going to uh he was going to make
a statement now here's um here's vivec
on Fox news of course Fox News is the
only one that carried this little press
conference and all's he's saying here oh
there's Texas Paul
I think I got you back am I got you back
yeah I'm here oh okay yeah yeah I'm not
sure that you're for whatever reason you
um you can't uh kicked from the from the
audio or something
um here is vivec standing in front of
the courthouse telling all the other
candidates that he wants them to promise
that they're gonna pardon Trump just
like he's gonna pardon drum notice the
hat that he has on is a true social hat
and if you if you can't see behind the
Chiron this says truth behind it it
almost feels like to me Vivek is on the
Trump's payroll I don't know maybe it's
just me but tell me you're on the Trump
payroll without telling me on the Trump
Halo let's listen
so the bottom line is there are two
things that matter
one is how are we going to hold the
Biden Department of Justice accountable
the first answer
is that yesterday
I submitted a
Freedom of Information Act request
a demand to the Biden Department of
Justice demanding what did Biden tell
Jack Smith what did Biden tell Merrick
Garland what did Merrick Garland tell
special prosecutor Jack Smith okay so
here's the thing this little [__]
foyer request when they get it [__]
slam dunked and thrown in the trash he's
gonna say see I told you they don't want
to tell us like dude you don't get to
[__] see that in the middle of a
federal investigation everyone knows
that you [__] idiot that's not how it
works they're not going to give you a
request for information during an
investigation that would compromise that
investigation it doesn't matter what
information that you want that don't
exist they're not going to give you the
request of of information that doesn't
exist or does exist during this time
period just not something that's real
and they're decoupled from reality and
again this is vivec working for Trump
folks that's all this is if you're not
aware of this guy he's been on [__]
CNN they've I think they've had him on
Fox News several times I think he's been
on MSNBC anytime you see this guy or
hear this guy speaking I've listened to
him speaking spaces and I listen to him
speak in spaces months ago and the first
words that left his lips I could tell
this guy is running to be Donald Trump's
intended opponent
he is vivec you're welcome to come on
the show [__] too you can come
on the show and I will [__] ask you
questions you will have the ability to
[__] spew your garbage and I will
challenge you on it if you if you not
think I'm being fair but I am being fair
you're working for Donald you got a true
social head-on [__] oh let's
let's listen to what he wants other the
other candidates to do this is laughable
they are required within 20 business
days to give us an answer about any
direct or indirect communication and the
first announcement I want to make today
is that if they do not comply with the
law in the next 20 business days
then we will sue them in federal courts
at our campaign's expense to get to the
bottom of those answers do it the news
media should be doing this
it is a shame that a competitor to
Donald Trump in this election has to do
this he says competitor to Donald Trump
there he's not a competitor Donald Trump
he's being paid to run against Donald
Trump on purpose and to prop him up he
won't attack him he's trying to attack
DeSantis this is all [__] made up
[__] Texas Paul have you have you been
following this guy and watch this guy's
interviews and [__] A lot of people
blame the interview that Don Lemon did
with him is the reason why Don Lemon got
fired for CNN
yeah Chris Licht actually absolutely
freaked out because Don Don Lemon just
checked him right then and right then
and there and Chris left over who's now
out at CNN just freaked the hell out you
know I mean
right uh Gabe Sanchez is going to be
joining us in a moment and I've got a
special video that a viewer made
yesterday
um so I and I know I think that person
is in the chat so if you're and you know
what I'm talking about small rats if
you're in the chat and you made that
video yesterday hang on because this is
gonna have to do with the Twitter spaces
and uh and that sort of thing but I do
want to I again there's a lot of [__] to
show today Texas false I don't mean to
jump around so much but I gotta show
this too
um here's another person who doesn't
quite understand the politics of this
and doesn't understand that we've been
on doing for a long time Paul Ryan was
on uh CBS the mornings today
um talking about Donald Trump and how
they need to beat Donald Trump blah blah
blah and Paul Ryan still needs to pluck
his head out of his ass even even as a
board member of Fox News this guy
doesn't know what's coming
and he may know what's coming he's just
gaslighting people listen to this and
this one's National Security this one's
different I used to have these same
documents myself
um as Speaker of the House so I think
this goes beyond just um some petty
thing now my guess is Trump will play
this politically pretty well and make
this weaponization argument and make
this about Joe Biden's justice
department and that's going to have some
political saliency so I don't think
Marco's wrong in saying that there's
some political sting here but I can't
help but think the weight and the
baggage of all of this and this one's
National Security this one I think we
want a nominee who's not weighed down
with so much baggage in order to win
this election and it's really clear a
lot of our Suburban voters will not vote
for Donald Trump I can tell you how it
works in Wisconsin I can't imagine
Donald Trump winning Wisconsin he lost
it in 20 and do you think he's done
things since 2020 election like January
6 that make those swing voters want to
vote for him but why do you think he's
trying to hold the support that he has
though because he has a very good core
of support and he's got a good it's as
simple as that he's got a great core of
support in in in the primary that is
what you build off of and the reason why
he has that core support is because of
people like you Paul Ryan you
capitulated to him you normalized him
you acted like he should he should be
this way and this was the Republican
party it was you [__] you were
the Speaker of the House you had access
to this information you say you know
this National Security risk but you
didn't act like it when Donald Trump was
a national security arrest the entire
time he was President this is [__]
just 100 horseshit Texas ball
yeah and man I'm telling you I continue
on with that Bud Light Disney all of
them everybody's like oh well I'm like
you made this happen eat it eat it yeah
Disney you were uh donors to the
Republican you helped build this and now
you've got Nazi standing outside your
gate you did this
you did this 100 Paul you know Paul
Ryan's sitting there we're losing my
home state you know they're just not
going to vote for us and he ain't done
nothing since the last election to make
people like him
you did this man you 100 right you you
facilitated it all eat it right it's
your bed you [__] made it now sleep
in it [__] um let's finish up what Paul
Ryan has to say here and so it does
matter but my point is I think the
electability argument is going to become
more Salient with this indictment and
whatever happens in the future all the
exhaustion of all the Trump baggage nope
is going to make it easier now I think
to make the argument to his core
supporters he's not electable he's going
to cost us the Senate again he's going
to cost us more House Seats it'll cost
us the White House and we want to win
and we do want to win yeah so in this so
go look at what are these other great
conservatives that are in the race who
don't have all this baggage oh Paul
Ryan's trying to talk since into manga
good luck for Paul Ryan Paul Ryan be the
one to talk since in the manga you
people are [__] brain dead if you
think and I'm talking to Republicans
establishment Republicans that don't
want Trump to win you people are [__]
and brain dead if you think it's Paul
Ryan that are going to get out there and
talk sense into the cult members people
aren't aren't [__] paying attention
you just are not understanding how this
works Rhonda santis not only is he
awkward and weird and he couldn't win
the nomination even if Donald Trump
wasn't in the race he's not gonna win it
when he is in the race okay and he
definitely is not gonna peel off the
cult members who are going to be the
[__] steadfast
Republican primary voter Jesus Christ
Texas ball how is Paul Ryan this dumb
and it's not just him you know you know
Frank Lentz is that guy's usually smart
as hell I had to you know I wrapped him
on the knuckles on Twitter just
yesterday he's putting out a thing oh
man y'all were all wrong about Old
Donald Trump he's he's just solidifying
his base these indictments are just
making him stronger and inevitable to
win the White House [__]
everybody he lost that cost him he was
the incumbent folks you know how hard it
is for an incumbent to lose a freaking
election I mean he was the incumbent
president he literally held Republican
events in front of the White House I
mean he had every advantage in the world
and he lost
what has made him more appealing since
then
what what I mean Joe Biden's done an
amazing job I've got hell I've got a
list right here that I was going to work
on on tomorrow's show I'll throw it out
here today I don't give a damn
inflation's at a two-year low uh we've
got it's straight 11 straight months of
inflation follow we got wages Rising
we've got gas prices are down a buck 50
over from uh before Biden took office
you got Energy prices down 11 percent
you got grocery prices are trending that
eggs everybody [__] about eggs
they're down over 30 percent I mean it's
just one thing after another after
another that Joe Biden's doing right and
then over here you've got freaking mango
Mussolini screwing up every way he can
and it doesn't matter that a bunch of
idiot Hillbillies like we're showing in
these clips are gonna vote they're gonna
vote for him anyways I mean it doesn't
matter
they don't give two [__] about him what
matters is in the suburbs you're going
to lose half your Republican support
that's right you're not you're just not
going to show up they're just not going
to show up like I said in the front
um here is speaking of DeSantis and
attacking DeSantis and drawing wedges uh
in between this primary here's Sean
Hannity trying to interview Gavin Newsom
last night I really actually Dick's
watching the Clips of this it made me
think that Sean Hannity really thought
he he was going to get one up on Gavin
Newsom and Shawna he's like oh I'm
definitely smarter than Gavin Newsom
Gavin newsom's like here hold my beer
[__] because at every single turn John
and he couldn't quit [__]
tripping all over himself and trying to
stop Yaman Newsome from talking and the
reason why is because Gavin Newsom is
absolutely burning his house down but
here's one example when they're talking
about Rhonda santis and Rhonda Santos
shipping people from a non-border state
uh or as a non-border state Governor
from a border state to California listen
this they were told
changed they were dropped
off on the door and they left and there
was not coordinated I mean what kind of
Faith tradition everything else there is
a video humanization of the people
getting on the because they were all
lied to and told and they were being
taken care of everything's going to be
great I would be loud and happy then
then because by the way I have the RFP
because they landed in your Sanctuary
State you're going to take care of them
they should be happy look we'll we'll
deal with the car come on this is
California I know it's called okay
on this way the fourth largest economy
in the world we can handle of course we
have this okay I'm a border state Ron
DeSantis is not I know he's desperate to
get into the ACT no because a lot of
people Donald Trump is going to clean is
it this is the Joe Biden DeSantis belly
do you he will clean his clock I don't
have a crystal attention and he set this
up months ago by doing an RFP I have the
contractor okay my question I tried to
hire saying he was going to send people
so there's Gavin Newsom not only um
absolutely destroying Sean Hannity and
Rhonda Santos but showing that Joe Biden
didn't have anything to do with this
this is all political stunt and it's a
flop like the only people believing this
garbage are the people who are going to
vote for Trump anyways no one else is
paying attention to this stupid [__] no
one no one here's another clip of um
Gavin Newsom here uh talking about Joe
Biden and again in the front I would oh
my God uh I was uh yeah
all right oh he had someone waiting in
the wings let me show you this clip with
Jill biting them we'll go to who we get
and wait in the wings um this is this is
excuse me uh Gavin news from talking
about Joe Biden here and his successes
Texas Paul just goes to what you were
saying I think he's a man of decency and
character I'm really proud of the
president I'm proud of what he's
accomplished he's strong enough to be
president that's I'm strong enough but
he just did the McCarthy he ran look at
the vote card I wouldn't have voted for
it exactly Kevin got played by the
president United States I'm for results
I'm for results I don't think the amount
of the people benefit I like the plan
that would have saved 4.8 trillion all
right hello Sean Hannity shoveling
papers we've got someone in the studio
here I'm not sure who this is um welcome
to the show who and can I help you what
the
uh do you have a mic you can speak if
you like
no yeah I can't hear you can't hear you
apparently Maga can't run run
microphone oh my God what the [__] is
going on here
yeah now we can hear you there I'm just
saying I'm not gonna have my voice
suppressed okay oh really yeah is that
what it is I'm just as a fellow friend
fighting citizen a real Patriot letting
you know that Donald Trump is
being
framed
a lot of people are saying that this is
Maga Mario in the uh in the chat
wow oh my God Maga Mario
um you look a lot you look a lot like
someone else I know to be quite honest
yeah I mean you look a lot like
um
Sanchez who's this guy named Sanchez
okay so uh
as manga Mario uh doesn't try to break
character here yeah um
several days ago Gabe Sanchez was in a
Twitter space with Seb Gorka
um and Seb Gorka Sev Gorka is such a
piece of garbage that he couldn't just
call Gabe Sanchez a Mexican right he
want to do so bad I believe the gay that
that uh Seb wanted to call Gabe Sanchez
a Mexican in the space but what he did
was he pointed out Gabe's last name you
know to try to get the audience all
riled up that he has a a name that
appears and sounds Mexican but uh in the
space
I'm not say it say it it's a miyamaga
oh uh
Facebook's made him say it it's me Margo
it's a Mia Maga wait wait wait a second
wait a second do it do it again do it
again
hmm
small rats
oh man
um there is a video now that exists of
me and um Gabe Sanchez mocking not the
not Maga Mario here but me and Gabe
Sanchez mocking uh Seb for for pointing
out that Gabe's last name is Sanchez and
he he didn't want to outright call him a
Mexican he just wanted to point out that
fact in the Twitter space but we were
mocking him the other day and someone
may or may not mean small rants on
Twitter put a song together
um now this is a spicy meatball
Okay let's listen to this spicy meatball
Taco let's listen Chase
[Music]
that is
these days
[Music]
I can't trust that
he's a naughty boy he is such a naughty
boy
[Laughter]
I don't know how many times I listened
to that last night but it hadn't been a
thousand as soon as uh as soon as you
sent it to me last night I uh I played
it on repeat I was coming back from
Kinko's printing a prop and I've got uh
I've got a bit of a bit of a preview for
people oh really um yeah yeah
I loaded in I'll finish the full version
my
this thing is not apart
[Music]
big big problem I get it I get it but
anyway I was coming back from uh I was
coming back from Kinkos when you sent me
that video and I played it blasting out
of my car the whole like 10 minute drive
home it was pretty great oh it's it's a
great video and I want to thank uh small
rats he says [__] them here small rat uh
thank you very much for the um for the
entertainment last night it brought us a
lot of joy and I appreciate it you guys
are the best audiences I said you guys
you guys really come with the uh the
laughter uh in the chat you guys uh make
make politics and The Drudge uh politics
upbeat and this is certainly uh upbeat
uh for taking our uh taking our voice
the other day when we were mocking uh
Seb Gorka and we tagged Seb Gorka
several times so I hope he got to see it
too because uh [__] him as well
um but uh here here's you said you were
you were working on a bit here for a
commercial a new commercial yeah and
here's the preview this is the preview
okay so let's let's show the preview
here are you suffering from Trump
arraignment syndrome do you find it hard
to accept that your favorite former
president might have committed a few uh
oopsies well worry no more introducing
trumpet all the only medication
specially designed for Mac Republicans
who just can't accept that Trump is a
criminal with trumpet all you'll
experience a complete denial of reality
right when you need it the most trumpet
all specifically targets areas of your
brain so that you'll be convinced it was
all a deep state conspiracy a Witch Hunt
or maybe just a huge misunderstanding
who knows certainly not you
so so I I can't wait for the release of
the product trumpet all then yeah yeah
so that was exactly I think I think it
might be already out because I had this
conversation yesterday on Twitter with
this woman that told me I needed to get
in
find out about Q I'm not kidding
yesterday told me I had to find out
about q and then I'm gonna find out that
this is Trump is in control of all of
this
yeah
it must be true that in Texas Paul She
said that [__] on Twitter drawing them
out that's what he's doing he's drawing
him out
he's playing in the swamp yeah I'm
telling you what she had about three
bottles of trumpet all in a box of cheap
wine I guarantee you well she maybe
she's part of the clinical trials of
trump at all that may be what it is
she's just part of those clinical drugs
does she have uh did she did she say if
she had the uh
I haven't we haven't gone there yet we
played a few clips of Gavin Newsom and
but we haven't gotten to uh the the fake
ass Biden tapes that they keep that
Chuck Grassley went to the senate floor
last night and tried to convince us that
there was these Biden tapes that way
they could get out of the media this
morning and try to run cover for Donald
Trump being arraigned on 37 Federal
felonies because I mean did they did
they play the tapes because even uh uh
uh
prostate Jack prostate said he was going
to play he was like should I play the
tapes on Tim cast tonight and it's like
stop [__] talking about just release
the [__] tapes man well you have to
show you [__] tapes Jack Frosting
because he doesn't have anything he
didn't add me blocked so I was able to
uh quote tweet him let's see if I can
find it here Jesus Christ there's
someone's [__]
Rudy gave Bill Barr the tapes over lunch
and Bill Barr ate the tapes
is that why yeah
I mean it's just you hear because Tony
and I were texting last night and he
sent me uh Jack's tweet or his quote
tweet and I was like look
if you have actual evidence if you're
like man this is damning evidence this
is going to wholeheartedly 100
undeniable
uh going to prove that he took money
Hunter Biden Joe Biden they're all
corrupt the whole Biden family
if you have evidence to prove that
somebody committed a crime
then the evidence should be able to
stand on its own and speak for itself
trying to have to [__] fluff it and
talk it up and talk about how you got
these documents and then the and then
the informant and The Whistleblower goes
all the all go missing whistleblower and
then you're like oh and we just happened
to get these tapes 17 tapes that this
person was just holding on to you're
gonna tell me this person had these
tapes the whole [__] time well you
know the crazy part and they didn't play
it during 2020 get the [__] out of here
you know what you know what the problem
is is Jim Comer said on Newsmax that
they didn't actually have the tapes and
they can't verify them they just know
there are 17 tapes which is all [__]
it's just a [__] it's something
someone said later today and last night
but here's here's what Jack said last
night he said should I go on Tim cast
tonight and drop receipts on the Biden
tapes in Ukraine yeah I said you won't
you [__] [__] you won't do it you
won't do it because you don't have it
you're full little [__] [__] man let
me guess let me guess he went on to Tim
cat I didn't know if he was on Tim cast
last night but because I'm gonna I'm
gonna assume also when you say
you you look go back to that too real
quick look at the phrasing the way that
he tweeted that
the wording in this tweet says
should I go on to timcast to drop the
receipts on the Biden tapes it's not
should I go on the Tim cast and drop the
bite in tapes it's right receipts
they don't have tapes they've got
nothing no it's all [__] well and it
is real convenient Texas Paul that they
did this the night before that Chuck
Grassley I'm gonna play the the clip
here after you get done comment
commenting here that Chuck Grassley goes
on the senate floor and says these lies
it's real convenient that it happened
last night don't you think
yeah I mean it it's all a distraction
trying to give their their crazy old
toothless dumb bastard something to hold
on to but they just I and I think about
this for just a second how far this your
your brain has to be freaking rung out
to believe this [__] okay you're telling
me a guy that lost the Civil War in
barisma that had Putin's people kicked
out of the damn country has been taken
over he lost man
but he has these tapes that he just for
some reason hasn't really given up to
anybody but then you're going to say oh
no well he gave them you know to to Bill
Barr
who just really thought you know the
bidens deserve to pass on this one you
know we got these tapes where they're
saying oh yeah give me some bribes you
know but you know we're not going to
play those tapes for anybody we're just
going to go ahead and rewrite the
Mueller report and all that other [__]
that bill Barr did but we're not going
to let these tapes out of the bag you
know I mean how opened up the Durham
investigation and and coordinated with
the special counsel Jim or uh John
Durham in his investigation you mean
that same bill bar the same bill bar
that went on TV the other day went on TV
the other day and said I protected
Donald Trump he said it the [__] out
loud he said I did everything I could to
protect Donald Trump when I thought he
was being railroaded is what Bill Barr
said you think that guy wasn't gonna
[__] help get these Biting Down
States out in the open wall what see
what Chuck Grassley has to say Old
National who allegedly bribed Joe and
Hunter Biden allegedly audio recordings
of his conversation with them
17.
such recordings
according to the 1023
the foreign National possesses 15 audio
recordings of phone calls between him
and Hunter bike
according to the 10 23
the foreign National possesses two audio
recordings of phone calls between him
and then Vice President Joe Biden
these recordings were allegedly kept as
a sort of insurance policy for the
foreign National in case that he got
into a tight spot okay so here's the
thing here's the thing this is all 100
horseshit meaning meaning that anyone
can go give any statement they want like
this to the [__] FBI has to
investigate it again because he goes
allegedly gave bribes so so they're
they're trying to push this idea because
what what they're hoping for obviously
is that
they don't have evidence they don't have
any sort of proof these whistleblowers
aren't actually whistleblowers these
informants aren't actually informants
there's somebody told them something
they wanted to hear right Maga is so
desperate to get what they want
or sorry not get what they want to hear
what they want is that they will now go
out on the yes you're damn right
Carol I don't mean to interrupt the
important conversation here but Carol
Carol says from yeah or um from YouTube
porn stash now we are zero days we are
now zero days again
um uh talking are not talking about porn
I just want to point out go ahead with
your seriously with your serious point
there mustache Mario Mago with your
points if these hands could talk if
these tiny hands
oh my God somebody asked uh
anyways in the comments
um so so yeah you you've got this you've
got this group of people these people
who are so desperate right to confirm
their own bias
am I the Italian people I'm sorry I
can't I can't stop we're talking about
Espionage today I know people are
surmising that Gabe is an Italian spy uh
and Jane you're on whatever you know
this works so much better than a comb I
just want to say
I want to be serious but I can't I can't
I I did this [__]
you did in here you wore the [__]
stash what am I supposed to do what am I
anyway so the Republican party is so
desperate to hear what they want right
their confirmation bias to be confirmed
and validated that they will will say
they will walk as close to the line as
they can by saying allegedly this guy
was bribed oh well we allegedly have 17
tapes that somebody told us about this
alleged crime being done but we don't
actually have the tapes we can play you
the tapes we can't put them in the
record because we don't actually own we
haven't seen we haven't even we haven't
even gotten a photo of the tapes that
say Biden tapes on them right
they have nothing at all and again going
back to the point of they're trying to
push this out there and it's funny well
to try to position out there for the
arraignment but it's funny because in
these Twitter spaces and other places
they're like oh oh wow Trump was
arraigned right when these Biden tapes
were coming out and right when the 5
million bribe the 5 million dollar bribe
came out and it's like they're saying
the quiet part out loud they're doing
this tape thing to distract from the
Trump arraignment You Got It reversed
and also the fact that like these things
were done all the way back in May and
April of 2022 when they attempted to get
these things back and that it wasn't
until you know months later when an
investigation was started
[Laughter]
you know it's a bunch of Hero's wife
[Music]
if she wants to call me she can totally
call me never seen her before but I'm
willing to
um
go ahead go ahead now you know what I'm
gonna do because you know I got kind of
that messed up sense of humor if I ever
actually do run for Congress and win you
got to do that that background
investigation with the FBI where they
right determine whether you can have
clearance or not in the middle of that
in the middle of that I am going to say
into the microphone I am showing you a
picture of my penis running down the
right leg of my pants and when I get an
erection it is so long I can't bend my
knee and then go on with the interview
and then go on with the interview and
then when I'm in office I'm going to
demand that the FBI produced the
interview notes that proves that when I
get an erection I cannot bend my right
knee
proof right well and that's really what
they're doing right Texas fall so what
they're doing is pulling out a a [__]
a uh a [__] FBI interview that was
done by some [__] idiot who hates
Hunter Biden who hates Biden who loves
Trump it's probably an operation against
them to be quite honest and it's a
document that exists because they wrote
down what this dumb son of a [__] said
and because they wrote it down that oh
he's got 17 recordings that don't exist
now the Republicans are like see here's
clear-cut evidence that recordings exist
I mean this guy's mind we don't have the
because they aren't saying I gave said
they're they don't they're not saying
they have the recordings because they
don't because they don't exist it's just
someone told the FBI that they exist and
that's what this report is just because
this person said this to an FBI agent
the FBI agent made a note of it doesn't
make it real folks it doesn't make it
real or the fact that they looked into
it and they're like there's nothing here
but again if this person actually had 17
tapes and they're like oh they were just
waiting because that's the narrative
they were just waiting for the fear that
they were gonna be you know [__]
whatever right they were gonna be
someone was going to Target them
the idea I can't I can't I can't with
you [__] you people in the chat oh my
God what on YouTube says tripod Paul
what the [__] Texas not Texas Paul
tripod Paul from now on from now on from
here forth we call Texas Paul tripod
Paul it is
Tuesday with tripod
oh my God oh my God hey Paul I'd hate to
tell you but you just torched your uh
your campaign to be a congressman when
you when when we just uh deemed you
tripod pole
oh man oh wait wait wait wait wait wait
week uh we have breaks I guess we
already knew these charges right but it
sounds like it sounds like Trump has
arrived at the Miami Courthouse by the
way oh really yeah well I guess we're
not gonna actually see him yeah yeah go
ahead Tony let me ask you something real
quick
um you know he's got to do that
interview right that one where he
discloses his bank accounts he hands
over his path he's got an interview oh I
know how much would you love to be a fly
on the wall when that low-level
government
clerk in the courthouse sits across from
him and says give me your account
numbers you cannot travel beyond x
number of counties and just reads him
the riot act on everything that now
because he is now going to be indicted
and then arrested that's a lot a lot of
people he's not just being arraigned
today he will be arrested he may release
him on his own personal recognizes but
Donald Trump is getting arrested today
he is how much would you love to be
there for that so let me tell you about
this
um I may or may have not done one of
these as an experiment just as an
experiment so here's the thing is that
when when you when you get arraigned um
on charges and you're indicted on
federal charges they do what's called a
pre-trial interview and they do your
they do your they do your um
uh
are you looking at comments is that what
you're doing they they do I don't know
which one he's referring to they do they
do an interview and they ask you about
like what prescription drugs you take
what drugs if you have a drug problem if
you have an alcohol problem
um have you ever been in rehab I mean
they ask you all kinds of questions have
you ever done drugs before what drugs
have you done before in the past I mean
they ask you all these [__] questions
they write to them it's all part of your
pre-trial condition because they're
going to assign you a pre-trial officer
and that pre-trial officer has to know
do you have a drug problem do you not
have a drug problem does this guy does
this guy not have money do they do have
money where's the money where do they
live what places do they stay how do we
restrict their travel I mean there's
like Texas Falls saying there's all
these things but also they start up this
process of making sure if you are found
guilty or you take a plea deal that you
that that they do up the sentencing
guidelines because in the federal court
they're sentencing guidelines that they
have to follow and that the the office
actually gives the judge the actual
guidelines of what they say and by point
and it's a stupid point system and
really it's kind of what's wrong with
our sentencing uh in this country
um and and with the court system the
federal court system in the first place
but it but it just it gives the the
judge an idea and we saw this with
Stuart Rhodes right the prosecutor had
what they wanted to sentence him with
and then they had the guideline
sentencing
um that that that the pre-trial office
did and then the judge handed down his
sentence so there's three different
things there and that's what Texas Paul
is talking about and and we'll probably
never actually see
those records
um until probably sometime in the very
very very very far future uh with a
actual foia request Vivek an actual one
that will actually work
um that isn't that you don't have the
right to uh for you uh on certain things
but yes um he is I would love to be a
fly on on Donald Trump's head not Mike
Pence's head in this case on Donald
Trump said when he is giving this
interview to see what kind of stuff he
which comment were you laughing at I
wanna I'm not telling you
I would love I would love to be there
when that guy flips that file around and
as he's telling him these things he's
saying initial here
initial here an initial here
I'm going to need your signature right
here and Donnie's gonna sit there and
he's going to with his Sharpie gonna
have to write out that big ridiculous
freaking signature and that guy's gonna
close up that file on him and put it in
his briefcase and Donny's Gonna Know
forever and ever amen that is court
record that and it will come out it will
come out it will absolutely come out
apparently this was just a bit ago on my
way to the courthouse which ones and
then he's gonna be and then he won't be
able to message tweet at all
yeah because he can't have his cell
phone because they're also gonna they're
probably gonna hold them in they're you
know they're gonna all right they're
gonna go through the processing then
they're you know quote unquote arrested
right where he'll just like sit in like
some conference room with [__]
Marshals and Secret Service and he's
gonna be there for I don't know how long
but he won't be able to do anything
except just sit there
with his own thoughts and wait for them
to come through and he'll do the
signatures like Paul said
but he can't do [__] he can't do I mean
he's gonna I think I saw a report that
uh they they believe he'll fundraise
like two million dollars off of this
which is insane which is insane
but not so surprising that that he'll be
able to make two million dollars off of
these [__] idiots you wanna you wanna
see uh you wanna see there's something
breaking for you right there okay what
is it actually surrendered yeah he's
surrendered under arrests here is right
now as we speak here is Maga tears from
Marco Rubio this one of the senators
from Florida uh just just a little bit
ago about 15 minutes ago or so
um while Trump was driving to the White
House apparently he's crying here I'm
saying there's a lot more damage done
there with sources that are protected by
the Press than there is by the
allegations if proven in this indictment
meanwhile we are watching in real time
the damage this is doing to our country
it's it's further polarizing us at a
time when we have to be United behind
some things like what do we do about the
fact that we've given away our jobs
de-industrialized Americans America have
a shortage of medicines including cancer
medicines in our country China's
expanding all over the world our
military is eroding and its capabilities
vis-a-vis China uh you name it I mean
the destruction of the family
destruction of community instructions
being overrun we're not focused on any
of this stuff we're focused on an
indictment that frankly has no harm and
no victim associated with it the reason
why we're focused on it Marco is because
you [__] buffoons keep holding him up
in your party that is why we are focused
on it if you would have abandoned him
after January 6 and you Marco Rubio as a
sitting United States Senator would have
voted to remove him you [__] scumbag
if you would have done that we wouldn't
be talking about this today we'd be
going yeah he's a [__] criminal what
do you want what do you want lock him
away that's what we would be talking
about but you Marco you you little
[__] [__] you are the reason why we
were talking about this today because of
actions that you have made and have not
made you [__] piece of garbage ah
sorry I didn't mean to I had to get
I've got a quick uh a quick uh live shot
of uh of people down at the courthouse
if you want to show this uh this is uh
okay this tweet um let me get it up here
let me get it up here this is a quick
shot of people down at the courthouse
um this is 100 real why are you pulling
that up I mean yeah we have the best
equipped best trained military in the
world period all that [__] that Rubio
just said our economy is literally
number one in the world I don't know
where he's talking about this
de-industrialization and all this other
BS you know you know what else you know
what else it can't build factories fast
enough you know what else that border
that he's talking about since title 42
expired no one's really coming across
the border and that's something and
that's some here's a live shot this is
what Trump supporters think they look at
this is a live shot down there from from
the courthouse in Florida this is what
it really looks like just saying it's
real it's it's the it's the tens of of
of protesters that are there to defend
Donald Trump right real Patriots Yeah
okay that you know imagine being the guy
pull that back up for a second could you
imagine being the guy that has the mop
the sweat off that belly to put them
tattoos on because you know they got to
be able to put the print down it's got a
stick I mean yeah can you imagine the
guy that had to take and just rub that
sweat off that here let me lift your
titty up rub that I mean come on man
[Music]
let me tell you something ever since
Maga Mario got here this show is just
not been as serious as it was before and
something about that to me
oh my god oh my god well everyone we're
gonna have more news tomorrow on this I
know I know we are um Texas Paul do you
have a Shameless plug uh before I um get
out of here and we show the audience one
last clip Catch Me Not only do I have a
plug I have an apology oh this new
Wednesday show is was new for me and I
was sitting there in my last Wednesday
show just clicking along
for you know I'm used to doing the
Sunday show only and and Miss Texas Paul
is texting me it's 10 55.
she's texting me again it's 11 o'clock
Boom the door flies open it's 1105. and
then I'm like what's the problem man I
go along all the time you know this is
I'm just what the hell man and then I'm
talking to people well I guess I got to
get going to get off the phone and she
looks at me it's Wednesday
oh [__]
so I apologize Tony I ran 15 minutes
over that will not happen tomorrow no
listen so
um this is I'm talking to Miss Texas
Paul here
um directly
um I gave permission to redirect all she
got to do is go in while he's
broadcasting this shut his broadcast off
and it will automatically redirect to me
just like in the middle of a sentence
too like enjoy the power just like this
and it'll automatically it'll
automatically redirect if you redirect
to our link it'll go right to us next
time that way I'm not even lying Tony
she is a huge fan of yours man as soon
as I ran over that 11 o'clock my door in
my office
it wasn't about you running over it's
just that she had to listen to you and
me both and she didn't want to have to
do that is that what it is I I want to
play this one last time um and everyone
go watch Texas Paul show you can follow
everywhere the link is down below in the
description just go to realtexaspaul.com
again it's realtexaspaul.com go go
follow him on all the socials and follow
his show on Sunday and Wednesday and if
you do the Wednesday show tomorrow
hopefully
um Miss Texas Paul can pull the plug on
him and it'll automatically redirected
this show
um that way that way you don't have any
complications there
um and Gabe Gabe he's got more um stuff
coming that was a preview earlier
but I know there's more videos coming so
good and that's the reason why I'm
wearing this outfit is because I was
literally I was shooting oh okay outside
and inside so you're gonna see something
with the manga Mario here soon yep
exactly okay okay well so go to what was
thatshow.com or go to patreon.com I am
Gabe Sanchez that way you can see all
the new stuff that he's going to be
putting out there on patreon while
you're on patreon check mine out at
patreon.com the Tony Michaels don't
forget to freaking subscribe right here
on YouTube don't forget as you leave
subscribe to YouTube you're not going to
want to miss a thing hit the Bell
notification we're here every single
weekday just like Texas Paul said
tomorrow on Wednesday but every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for two
pool hours sometimes a little over like
we are today because we are screwing
around with the porn stash um you can
watch us on Facebook as well uh at Tony
Michaels at the Tony Michaels go follow
us on Facebook and watch us there you
can watch us on the up bars Channel
theupwire.com or just type in the up
wire on YouTube you can find us there
subscribe to the up wire and also I want
to thank everyone over on Twitch big
audience today on Twitch and we've had a
lot of people follow us on Twitch go to
twitch.tv Tony Michaels you can follow
us there for free you can also link your
Twitch account to your Amazon account
and give us that one free subscription
you get with your Prime account and we
get a couple bucks each month you know
what's free you know what's free to
download this show you can download it
every single afternoon after I get it
edited and uploaded you can go download
it on Apple Spotify and Google it's free
99 you get a five finger discount on all
directories of the Tony Michaels podcast
because it's free free free there
it's been a great show it's going to be
a great day I'm looking forward to um to
the actual arraignment and all the news
coming out of it and more more than
anything I'm looking forward to Grandpa
Poopypants stupid [__] statement and
his whiny little [__] statement
tonight and we will cover that tomorrow
you can Garen damn T it it will be right
here on the Tony Michaels podcast just
as we are every single weekday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific until
tomorrow
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon
Chase
[Music]
do everything peace with the last name
same Chase
Chase
what are you talking about that's a
personal attack oh oh I see the winner
these are these immature people on stage
[Music]
[__] Chase
Chase
I can't trust that
that dips again he's a naughty boy he is
such a naughty boy